[Music]
naomi judd has died
she was 76 years old whatever we're
going through comes out in our music the
three most important words in the whole
universe are love faith and hope
a rep for naomi tells e.t the country
music star died on saturday outside of
nashville tennessee
no cause of death has been revealed at
this time
she survived by daughters ashley and
wynonna and larry strickland her husband
of 32 years ashley shared this message
to instagram quote today we sisters
experienced a tragedy we lost our
beautiful mother to the disease of
mental illness we are shattered
sometimes i see myself
as
the embodiment
of mom and winona because i have a lot
of moms wandering spirit
and i have a lot of wine owners love for
life
the country music world shared tributes
to the icon on social media
carrie underwood wrote
country music lost a true legend
john rich called her quote one of the
most iconic entertainers to ever make
country music
mickey guyton shared quote rest in power
naomi judd the news came a day before
naomi and wynonna who made several chart
toppers as the judds were set to be
inducted into the country music hall of
fame and the fans just
they will never have a clue how they've
inspired me and what they've meant to me
i love her so much we're so close it's
scary
it's the most complex relationship in
the universe the mother-daughter
parent-child relationship period
following the news stars shared their
reactions with e.t at the white house
correspondents dinner i've met her i
spent time with her and i'm devastated
not only
for the country music world but
especially for her daughters who i've
also met and i know i just know when i
saw the news it's very shocking and
stunning she's about to go on tour with
wynonna as you know we wish the whole
family well right now